I'm federal. I'm DHS. Officer arrested for DUI tries to stop
the arrest by racially profiling the officers arresting him.
Do you guys see this? This is I've heard this is insane. I have
not actually watched it yet because I'm trying to save it for
stream. But we've got this and then there's an
body cam video that's out there. I just want to watch this as
a quick teaser and then we'll go into the actual video. >> I'm
federal.
>> I'm trying to get home. I got my boys with me. Who do
you work for? DHS. >> Do you have your ID with you? >> No,
I don't. >> Okay. But if I called them, they'd verify that
you're a >> 100%, bro. >> Okay. You don't have any
type of credentials or anything to say you're
>> Not on me? No. >> Okay. All right. >> I
only bring my weapon with me if I'm if >> Okay. But you
don't have any weapons? >> If you're What? What do you
mean you only bring your weapon with you? It's >> on you
right now. >> No, I don't. >> Okay. So, what I want
to do, I want to talk to away from the kids. So, I'm going to
ask you to step out of the car and we're going to walk back to
the back of your car. Okay. >> Are you serious? Right.
>> You know what? Call my supervisor.
>> Okay.
Do you want to do the exercises or >> I'll do it. >> Okay.
All right. I don't want to watch too much of this before we get
to the actual full video here. Okay. I don't want to I don't
want to bury the lead too much. Let's get Let's get going with
the full video. Here's 34 minutes body cam footage. Okay. Real
crime piece
or the crime piece.
We're going to try to pinpoint exactly where you find out that
this guy's maybe a little toasted. All right. >> Did you
wrote on the the back windows for me, too? >> Oh, trust
me, Curio. I know it makes it makes it seem like there's going
to be a bunch of dead air in here, right? There's not. He
Trust me, there's it goes different
>> Sorry, you got you got real dark. Hello, Scott. Where
are you coming from?
Miami down here to uh >> uh give me two seconds here. I
just need to grab some water real quick. >> So, you're
coming from Miami to Isa Marada and then you're going back to
>> Yeah, I live in Miami. >> Okay. Do you know where
you are right
>> What where are you? >> I got the overpass over
here, 18 mile stretch overseas highway. >> Okay. Where
where did you uh where did you do today? What'd you go? Did you
go fishing? Did you go >> to a restaurant?
Well, you you're you're about 100 miles off of where you think
you are. >> Well, no, >> you are. >> Who is
the guy in the white shirt? >> That's the colonel. >> Colonel,
tell me.
Okay. Well, >> uh, I'm federal.
>> I'm trying to get home. I got my boys with me. >> Who
do you work for?
>> Do you have your ID with you? >> No, I don't.
>> Okay. But if I >> Wait, what? 100 miles? 100 miles
off?
He's a 100 miles.
Wait, hold on. Do we Do we see in here where he got actually
picked up? That's
dude. He's like, "Oh, yeah, cuz I could tell." Hold on. If we
go back, I shouldn't have I shouldn't have walked away. We go
back. Dude, he clearly has no idea where he is, right? They're
like, "Do you know where you are right now?" And he's like, "Well,
you know,
we're on the highway here. That's the ocean overpass.
It's like, okay. Uh, >> where did you uh where did you
do today? What'd you go? Did you go fishing? Did you go Marada?
And you're going back to >> Yeah, I live in Miami. >> Okay.
Do you know where you are right
>> What where are you?
>> Like that's You've already lost. You're already totally
right. Oh, where are you right now? He puts his hand out. He
like stretches his hand out. Um
uh yeah, you're toasted. Like, how the [__] are you
driving a vehicle? And there's no vehicle without GPS nowadays,
right? How the [__] are you driving a vehicle? Or
if you don't have GPS, you really know where you are, right?
And you're driving this vehicle, you can't even say like, I'm
on this highway. You can't say I'm between these two places.
>> The overpass over here.
>> We got the overpass over here.
Well, you know, I I did just go over some water. There's an o
or a highway. There's an overpass back there. Yeah. Yeah. >> Overseas
highway. >> Okay. Where where did you uh where did you
do today? What'd you go? Did you go fishing? Did you go >> on,
bro? >> A restaurant.
>> What? You're you're about 100 miles off of where you
think you are. >> Well, I'm not. >> You are. >> Who
is the guy in the white shirt? >> Uh, no, I'm not. Uh,
fake news. You are fake news. >> That's the colonel. Colonel,
tell me. >> Okay. Well,
>> I'm federal.
>> I'm trying to get home. I got my boys with me. >> Who
do you work for?
>> Do you have your ID with you? >> No, I don't.
>> Okay. But if I called them, they'd verify that you're
a >> 100%, bro. >> Okay. You don't have any type
of credentials or anything to say you're
>> Not on me. No. >> Okay. All right. >> I
only bring my weapon with me if I'm if I'm doing >> You
don't have any weapons on you right now? No, I don't. >> Okay.
So, what I want to do, I want to talk to away from the kids.
So, I'm going to ask you to step out of the car and we're going
to walk back to the back of your car. Okay. >> Are you
serious right now? >> Yes, sir. I am >> kidding,
mate.
>> It's okay. We're just going to walk back to the the
back of the truck and we'll have a conversation. Okay. >> Yeah.
Well, doing that job. >> Thanks, sir. I appreciate it.
>> Just walk like right. >> Couldn't open the door.
I don't know if he was like trying to situate himself. Yeah,
it took him a long time to get out of there. Over here, >> guys.
Please come over here for me.
Okay. Um, so you said you're coming from Miami, going to Isa
Marada, and going back to Miami. What are you going to Mara for,
>> seriously, are we are we really doing this right now?
>> Oh, and he's sluring. I That was slow, too. Are we really
doing this right now?
>> I'm just asking a question. You said you're going to
Isa Marado. What are you What are you going to Isam Marada for
>> Lane? Yeah. Are we really doing this right now, >> dude?
Oh, >> sir. I'm just asking you a simple question. You
don't have to answer if you don't want to, but you say you're
going to Alamada, so I'm just asking what you're going for, >> bro.
Apparently, they let this guy off with a misdemeanor. They don't
even like arrest him. They let him apparently they let him go,
or I mean, he gets misdemeanor. I don't know if they let him
go, actually, but he gets misdemeanor for this. This is not even
a felony. It's not even like a standard >> guys. Zack,
how much have you had to drink today? >> Uh, four. Four.
What? >> Oh my.
Seriously,
bro. I can't imagine. You know what the You know what the only
answer is to that question, right? We all know what the only
answer is there. The only answer is zero. That's the only answer
you ever give the cops.
>> That's the only one. You never give them another answer.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Don't you know I'm a Yoshifa?
>> Jesus Christ. Thank you, Reuben. What? For drinks, like
water, alcohol,
beer. What'd you drink,
>> dude? That's by the way, you you don't hear it quite,
but that's the officer being merciful there. Four waters, right?
Tell me four waters so I don't have to like Please tell me four
waters so I can be merciful here. Do not actually tell me the
truth. Like, four waters, right? Four waters.
>> Kool-Aid. Are you guys really trying to me right now?
He's actually trying very hard to keep you from going to jail
right now. And you showed no appreciation for this >> I'm
just asking what you you look like you're impaired. I smell alcohol
coming from you. So I'm just asking how much you had to drink
to make sure you're not too impaired to drive that vehicle. Okay.
How about this guy? So again, I think that you might be impaired.
You You look Your eyes are bloodshot. They're kind of glassy.
>> Are they really? >> Yes, sir. They are. >> Show
me. >> I don't >> I don't know how you want me to
do that. >> Produce a mirror right now. prove to me that
my eyes are bloodshot. >> Take a picture.
>> Okay, we could we could do that in a minute. Um, but
the other reason why I think you're impaired is just the way
you're walking. You're kind of stumbling a little bit. >> I'm
not walking anywhere.
>> Okay. And then also the way that you were seen, >> bro.
You were grabbing on to the bed of that truck like a like a lifeboat.
Okay. You're grabbing onto the edge of that like it was your
only lifeline in this world. And if you let go, you were going
to go spiraling off into the sunset. >> I think you're
like kind of swerving and stuff. And then the the colonel tried
to pull you over and you didn't immediately stop. You stopped
here on the bridge. He tried to stop you at a safer spot a little
bit back there.
>> we're doing this.
>> Okay. So again, I believe that you may be impaired by
alcohol andor some type of chemical substance which may inhibit
your ability to operate a motor vehicle
So I'm going to ask that you voluntarily participate in standardized
field sobriety exercises to dispel my belief you may be impaired.
Are you willing to do those exercises? >> You'll do them.
>> Okay. So, what I'll do, you can just sit on the on the
bumper.
>> I Oh, I'm excited. I feel like Dude, he looked he looked
up trying to answer questions. He was grabbing onto that side
of the vehicle to walk to the back, right? I can't believe that
he's going to try to do these exercises. This going to be him
like doing the alphabet backwards, right? Trying to walk a straight
line. And >> your car right there. You're a little bit
taller. I just need to look at your
>> guys. Look.
I'm SFSD certified. >> Okay. So am I. I'm a drug recognition
>> You know what that is? Okay. Anyway, so what I'm going
to have you do, uh, if you can uncross your feet and just put
them like side by side. Perfect. And then your arms, if you could
try to put them down by your side like that. Okay. So, what I'm
going to have you do is just keep your head straight and you're
just going to keep your head like aim straight at me basically.
And then I'm going to look at your eyes. Okay.
You understand? Yep. >> Are you diabetic?
>> Are you epileptic? No. >> Okay. Do you have any
brain injuries?
I'm a disabled veteran.
>> Have you ever had a traumatic brain >> Yes, I
have. >> Okay. Does it >> affect your ability to
operate a >> Guys, come.
>> Okay. Well, I'm just asking what your brain injury is.
Does it affect you in your everyday life? >> Do you know
what nestagmas is? >> Onset of onset of nest.
>> Okay. But >> onset of nestagmas. >> It will
just be your pay.
Reban Ruben donated $3. This guys is on thin ice. Okay, I can't
do these puns anymore. It's making me feel a little cold inside.
>> Wow. Thank you so much, Ruben. Ruben, appreciate the
three buddies. >> Onset of nestagmas. Yes. >> Okay.
But do you know what nestagmus is? >> Yes, I do. >> Okay.
Do you have nestagmus?
>> Guys, are we really doing this? >> He's just going
to keep saying that every every 30 seconds. Are we really, guys?
Really? Guys, guys, are we really going to do this right now,
guys? Same team, guys. Are we really going to do this, guys?
>> Okay. Do you have any medical issues that I need to
know about?
>> Are you on blood thinners, painkillers,
>> I'm talking to you right now. I'm just talking to you,
man. It's all right. It's It's all right. Take a breath. If If
you're If you haven't drank too much to to not be able to operate
vehicle safely, then you know
>> Come on, guys.
>> We are both guys. >> Guys, come on, guys. I'm
going through a divorce.
Don't take my man. >> I'm not taking your >> Oh.
Oh, he's about to cry. He's about to alt. Did you hear the alt?
Did you hear the start of the alt there? Don't take my kids.
I'm going through divorce. Don't take my kids from me, man.
Oh, I'm starting to see why they I'm starting to see why this
guy didn't get a felony here. Okay, I'm seeing it. I'm seeing
exactly how this happened. >> Come on, guys.
We are both law enforcement.
I'm just I'm going through a divorce.
Don't take my man. >> I'm not taking your kids from >> Oh,
you hear the voice crack in there. Don't take my kids, man. Hey,
>> man. I'm just making sure that you're safe to drive
the car.
Okay. Do you have any other medical issues and I need to know
about? >> I don't know. >> Just any medical issues
that might blow up around me.
I've been shot at. >> Okay. Sorry, man. Take a deep breath.
>> Don't tell my kids. >> I'm not. You're all right.
Take a deep breath. You're okay.
>> I've been shot at. People have tried to kill me. I just
want to go home, guys. Come on, man. >> I got you, man.
>> We've been We've Come on. We know what's
>> He's He's literally throwing himself on their mercy.
He's literally just like, "Yeah, I really up, guys. I'm I'm literally
driving drunk with my kids right now. You got me uh Iraq pass.
Can I get my one Iraq pass? Listen, they sent me overseas for
oil. They told me it was for freedom. Come on. You got to give
me one. You got to give me I get one a get out of jail free card."
Right. >> We've been We've been down this road before.
Problem is is that we're at this point right now. >> I
understand that. >> And you know that I have to do what
I have to do. >> I understand that. But my boys are >> Okay.
Where's uh their mom at? >> I don't [__] know
that. >> Do they have anyone down here that would be able
to take care of them?
>> I'm not saying you're going with me, man. But you're
you're all worried about this stuff. I'm just trying to figure
out, you know, if there's someone else around here that,
you know, maybe they could come drive the car if you think maybe
you you drank too much to drive. >> Guys,
no. No. >> They're my everything. >> Okay. So, no
medical problem. Dude, if they're your everything, the are you
doing driving drunk enough that the cops pull you over with a
veteran plate? Right. Obviously, this guy must have been weaving
all over. Is there no Is there no dash cam footage? I want to
see the dash cam footage now cuz I feel like this guy's probably
weaving all over the place, right? Like you can't you can't endanger
the lives of your kids and then say, "Guys, don't take my kids
away from me. Your It sounds like your kids need to be taken
away from you. It sounds like your kids are in danger being with
you. If you care about them, you probably need them taken away
for at least some period of time so you can stabilize your problems
that are going to affect your ability to follow my finger. Okay.
So again, what I'm going to have you do is just keep your head
straight and I'm just going to have you follow the tip of my
finger with your eyes and I'm just going to go side to side and
then I'm going to go up and down and I'm going to do a circle
around your head. Do it >> and I'm going to tell you what
I'm doing before I do it. Okay. I'm not going to touch you or
anything but again I just want you to follow my finger with your
eyes and don't move your head. Do you >> Okay. Ready?
head to the side a little bit. There you go. Uh, okay. If you
can, can you just like make your head straight? You're kind of
leaning your head to the side a little bit. There you go. Uh,
so what I'm going to do now is vertical. So, I'm just going to
go up and down. Okay. >> Ready? Same thing. Just follow
with your eyes. Don't move your head. Ready?
>> I will just be your pay.
>> Oh boy. >> We Ruben donated $3. Ice guy suddenly
doesn't want to be separated from his kids. Wow.
>> It turns out what? Imagine how other people's feel.
Yeah, imagine how other people feel. Yes, Ruben Ruben. Exactly.
The irony. Listen, irony abounds in this situation. And and with
that, also with that donation, Reuben Ruben, thank you very much
for reminding me to shill. Guys, if you like the content, go
ahead, follow on every platform. It's
and patreon.com/jdlk.
Don't forget to join the Discord.
if you ever want to call in, have an argument, or if you just
want to be a part of a cool community. And if you really like
the stream, if you really like the content, you can go ahead
donate a couple subs, buy a TTS message, add some uh throw a
couple bucks my way, okay? Exclamation point. Donate in the chat,
we'll give you the links to buy a TTS message. If you donate
money, okay, you add more time to the stream, whether that's
dollars, bits, subs, anything. It all adds more time to the stream.
I appreciate all the support, guys. And uh and thank you very
much. One sec. I'm trying to grab this link and it will not let
me grab it. Jesus. Want to throw a link over in the Twitch. Thank
you guys very much. I'm not going to show for too
Okay. And now I'm going to do uh just two small circles around
your head here. I'll show you what it looks like. So I'm going to
go like this around your head. And I'm going to bring it in between
your eyes to your nose, but I'm not going to
>> um I think he was charged. Oh, somebody told me he was
charged with misdemeanor off of this. I saw that on a Reddit
post. I didn't actually look for a source on it. So we'll we'll
look deeper into it in just a second. >> Touch you. Okay.
So don't don't flinch or anything. I'm not going to touch you.
Okay. All right. Ready? >> All right. One more time.
>> Next thing I'm going to have to do is the walk and turn
here. I don't know how easy this would be for you to do in flip
flops or if it'd be easier in your uh >> lane. I just want
to get >> I got you, man. >> Come on, dude. >> I'll
tell you a true story. I went through the same thing two years
ago. >> You divorced?
>> I am >> I'm going through a divorce. >> That's
kind of dickish. I went through the same thing two years ago.
You getting divorced? No. >> Well, that was where his voice
cracked, >> Right now. >> Look, man. You I
you drank too much to drive car. No, I you didn't. Okay, let
me get my piss on.
>> You can't drive it far. >> That's the whole point.
You are too up to drive this car. You can't get your kids home
>> right now, man. Based on what I'm seeing so far, unless
you know if you do good on this, maybe I'm wrong. Okay, that's
why we're doing these. So that you can dispel my belief that
you're impaired.
Okay, because right now what I'm seeing the stumbling and stuff,
I want to see if you can do this stuff. >> Stumbling. I'm
not doing anything. I'm sitting right here. >> Well, no.
when you walked out of the truck at first, you kind of it it
looked like it. Maybe I'm wrong. Okay, but that's what this stuff
is for so that we can dispel that belief that I have that you're
impaired.
Okay,
so the next thing we'll do is the one leg or the uh the walk
and turn. Okay, so what I'm going to have you do is just put
your left foot on this line right here. If you can just step
forward. I don't want you to be touching the truck at all. Just
a little bit forward just so you're not next to the >> Your
right foot in front of your left foot touching heel to toe. >> Still
holding on. And if you can put your arms back down by your side
or try to stand there just in case.
>> All right. So again, just put your right foot back in
front and then your
>> Did you catch that? Oh, he just stumbled. He just stumbled
trying to get his feet into a straight line. >> Oh boy.
>> All right. So again, >> watch watch. Let's uh
let's uh let's slow it down right here. >> Right foot >> puts
his right foot there. Immediately falls back onto the back onto
the truck.
Oh boy. >> And then your arms straight down by your
>> There you go. Now just stay like that. If you
>> He can stay standing straight with his hands together.
Or sorry, with his feet. >> If you have to put your hand
up, just put it right back down. Okay. Okay. So, just stay like
that. Don't do anything else until I tell you to. Do you understand?
He >> immediately wobbles off the line. Dude, he's failing
this. He's not even putting up a good effort. He's like instantly
failing. He is instantly He is failing at the pre-check. Okay.
He cannot stand there. It's the wind for sure. You think so?
It's the wind. >> Okay. So, if you can just try to get
back into that position. >> I want to know.
>> Well, that part of the direct >> He's going to
buy some time. Can you Can you Mirandize me? I want to know my
>> Directions is that you're supposed to be standing like
that while I give the
>> That's okay. All right. Um, so the position that you're
supposed to be in right now is like this. Left foot on the line,
right foot in front, touching heel to toe. What I'm going to
have you do in just a second is I'm going to have you take nine
heel to toe steps down the line. I'm going to have you touch
every time. Heel to toe. Heel to toe. So heel to toe. Heel to
toe. You're going to keep your feet on the line. Okay? If you
stop walking or if you step off the line for any reason, I want
you to just put your foot back on the line and keep walking.
And I want you to count your steps out loud. Do you understand
so >> So again, just to recap where we're at right now,
your left foot is on the line with your right foot in front.
your arms straight down by your side. You're going to take nine
heel totoe steps. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine. Once you get to that ninth step, you're going to keep the
lead, the front foot on the line, and then you're going to use
your back foot to take a series of small steps to turn around.
>> Bro, this is this is a complicated >> And then
you're going to take nine heel to toe steps back down the line.
>> This is a long test, dude. If he's drunk, have a little
mercy. He's not going to remember all of this. Give them the
steps in order.
>> Do you understand so far? >> Okay. So, I'm going
to show you how it's going to look. Uh, so again, my left foot
is on the line like you. Steps like seven, eight, nine. >> How
do you get further away? >> How do you get further away
from the >> 3 4 5 6 7 8. >> As this guy showed him
the steps, he got further away from potentially doing the
>> Do you understand those instructions,
>> Okay. Could you get back in the starting position for
me, please? Dude, he's he's very quickly realizing that he's
right. He can't stand He can't even stand straight, let alone
take a step, put his heel and toe back together.
>> Just left foot on the line and right foot in front.
>> No, I got you, Lane. >> give me a minute.
>> dude. Just listen. Give me a minute. Give me a minute.
And I just need a moment. Listen, I lost I didn't tell you I
lost a comrade in Iraq, okay? And I'm going to give them a minute
of silence in their honor right now. Okay? Please do not interrupt.
Please do not talk to I'm just going to take a minute.
>> All right. You got it, man. You can do it. Okay. I don't
You don't
>> He's about to start crying again.
>> Listen, I feel like some amount of empathy for this
guy in that he's caught in a really rough situation of his own
making. It's like there's some amount of empathy. You're really
right now. It seems like you're really, but like ultimately you're
trying to use your kids as an out here when you're drunk driving
with your kids. You can't even walk straight,
right? So, while I feel like some empathy, ultimately, you are
not the victim here. Your kids are victims. The other drivers
on the roads are potential victims, right? You're not the victim.
You're not the person that I should feel any amount of concern
for in this >> I just don't want to be standing on the
side of the road any longer. >> [__] about
this, but >> Okay. Would you like to try the one leg stand
instead? >> I can show you the one leg stand if you'd like.
>> Give a [__]
>> Guys, I'm going through a divorce right >> We're
missing all this. A wife is trying to take my kids. >> It
sounds like you need to be away. I like it sucks, man, but it
sounds like you just made a decision to drive totally loaded
with your kids. I'm sorry. Like, man, it's I trust me, I feel
a lot of empathy for somebody who's showing this much emotion
as like a, you know, law enforcement officer, whatever. Probably
doesn't do it very much. But, dude, you I'm I'm sorry. Your your
kids need to not be around you right now.
>> Just give me a minute. All right.
Okay. Okay, man. We It's either a yes or a no. >> Just
give me a minute. All right, >> I I did give you a minute,
sir, but we can't we can't stand here for for this long. Okay.
>> Yes, sir. >> Federal law enforcement. I'm going
through a divorce. My wife is trying to take my kids. I'm just
>> my Give me a minute. All right. >> You know what
it's like. You know what it's like to be law enforcement. >> I
love anybody. >> Just give me a minute. All right, guys.
If we give you a minute, are you going to do the exercise? >> I
will do. >> Uh, by the way, this guy was giga charged for
felonies, by the way. Um, he was not let off the hook at all.
Although, I don't know if he was let off the hook originally
or not. He was definitely He definitely has now been charged
100%.
>> I got a new story now.
>> Okay. Like I said, I just don't like us standing here
in the road, man. >> I don't either, but you know what?
My kids are my life. >> I got you. >> No, they're
not. No, they're not. They're not your life, bro. You cannot
keep doing it. You cannot keep saying >> Like us standing
here in the road, man. >> I don't either, buddy. You don't
want my kids are my life. >> I got you. >> No, you
don't. Do you got kids?
>> Exactly. Do you have kids? >> Exactly. So, you
don't know what it's >> They're both stunned by his impeccable
rhetoric. Okay. They don't know what it's like, actually. They
don't They have no idea. They're totally defeated. Okay. This
guy This guy actually won. >> You know what? Call my supervisor.
>> Okay. He >> He took a minute. He tried to sober
up a little bit. He can still feel he's going to just fail this
immediately. All right, just call his supervisor. >> Do
you want to do the exercises or No, >> I'll do it. But
you know what? What's homeboy doing down there? You know, guys,
come on. Make sure
the hood. We don't want to get hit. We don't want you to get
hit. That's why I'm trying to do the exercise. That way we can
>> Oh, boy. Okay. I'm starting to see what made this clip
go viral. All right. You hear that accent he's speaking with
there? What do you think goes through an ICE officer's brain
when they hear an accent like that? Oh boy.
>> We don't want to get hit. We don't want you to get hit.
That's >> We don't want you to get hit, sir. >> So,
do the exercise. That way we can >> Are you Haitian? That's
not to be my wrist, but >> Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no.
Not a good thing. Listen, not a good thing, okay, to point out
while you're being stopped by the Asian cop or whatever. Also,
I think that guy might be Haitian. Is that Is this like an expert
level racist? Is that what they're hiring at ICE? Actually, is
this guy can identify that that Caribbean accent like perfectly?
Immediately knows it. He's like, "You're Haitian. I could tell.
I could see you. >> That's why I'm trying to do the exercise.
That way we can >> Are you Haitian?" >> That's nothing
to do with my wrist, but >> my question was, "Are you Haitian?"
>> It It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter where he's from.
>> Okay.
Look, man. I really need you to do the exercise. If you don't
if you don't do it, then I'm going to say that you're refusing
to do the exercise. I get it. You need a minute. I gave you a
few minutes. Okay. But >> let me talk to your supervisor.
>> Not right now, sir. >> That's not how this works.
You can talk to him. >> This guy This guy's just like,
"Oh, this guy's Haitian. Oh, I've got all the leverage back.
I just proved that this dude's Haitian. I can do whatever I want.
I run this now. All right. That dude's Haitian. Listen, my supervisor
have that guy out of the country in a week." All right. Yeah.
I run this now. It is how it works because you guys are
>> Okay? That's not a statute or a law or a policy or anything
that we have. He's the second from the top underneath it, the
sheriff. Okay? He's the one that pulled you over.
Okay? If you want to talk to him, we can. But right now, I'm
in the I'm in the middle of of an investigation, and you're not
going to talk to my supervisor in the middle of my investigation.
When I'm concluded with my investigation, whichever way that
goes, whether it's you in your car driving away or you in the
back of my car in handcuffs, if you want to talk to my supervisor
then, then by all means, you can. When I'm in the middle of an
investigation, it's you and me. No one else. Okay? So, this is
this is the last chance I'm going to give you. Okay? Do you want
to do the walk and turn >> What was that? It's you and
me, nobody else. And he's like, "Ah, I don't know about that."
He's like, "I this is Haitian. There's this guy who isn't even
American over here." >> Okay? So, this is this is the last
chance I'm going to give you. Okay. Do you want to do the walk
and turn >> Yeah, I'll do it. >> Okay. So, again,
put your left foot on the line
and then put your right foot in front touching heel to toe and
your arm straight down by your side. Okay. I'm going to show
you the instructions again real quick. Just uh if you if you're
confused and you think maybe maybe if you can't see it quite
all right. You think maybe he's now standing neutrally. No, he's
actually sitting on the back of his of his truck right now. Okay.
He's the reason he's not wobbling is he's actually just sitting
down on the back of his feet. >> So, refresh your memory.
Okay. So, left foot on the line, right foot in front touching
heel to toe. Six nine heel totoe steps. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine.
Keep the front foot on the line. Take the back foot off the line.
And you're going to take a series of small steps with the back
foot to turn around. And you're going to take nine go to toe
steps back down the line.
>> Do you understand the instructions? >> I do. >> I
want to talk to your Again, sir, once we're done with the investigation,
you are more than welcome to talk to anyone that you would like.
Okay, you may >> Go for it, dude. Dude. Oh, no.
Uh, how many He's failed four times. I think he's failed four
times already. Let's walk that back one more time. Uh, let's
here. Hold on. Let's get Let's get zoomed in on the feet. All
right, let's get zoomed in on the feet. Let's go a little slow-mo
here. All right. Uh, first step failure.
Okay, we can count this as resetting
except on his own shoe and he's already
Okay, lost once for sure at minimum. Lost once. Probably lost
twice.
He's definitely totally lost again.
Square pauses, arms out at his sides. I believe he's supposed
to have his Is he not supposed to have his arms at his sides?
Is he supposed to be doing the the oh, I'm balancing myself thing
out on the with the arms? I don't think so. They asked him not.
Okay. Oh no. Failed touch.
Did he just fall forward?
>> What a nightmare. Okay, it turns out this is the first
time this guy's ever worn flip-flops in his life and that's all
that's him right now. Okay, he's actually totally sober. He's
just never worn flip flops before and he doesn't even understand.
He stepped on the back of his heel and it rattled him
Online. No. No. Oh,
he's going offline.
brought it back. Oh,
>> okay. Awesome. >> Dude, he was on the way back.
That could have just about passed for Oh, he just tripped over
his sandals. >> Uh, so for the next one, the one leg stand,
we can come over here just so we're not in the road anymore.
This guy, can you walk over to me, please?
>> Do you want to do the one leg stand
>> All right. So, just take a couple steps forward like
right here.
>> Dude, you can't stop pretending that he is the victim.
>> Okay. Well, in order for me to instruct you on how to
do the exercise, I need you to stand over here. Awesome. Thank
you so much, Scott. So, if you can just put your feet together
with your heels touching.
Okay. And now put your arms straight down. Oh, I I
actually should have just been keeping a counter. Okay. New meme
for the next time we do anything like this. I need to keep a
counter and just count how many times he failed each field sobriety
test cuz I swear to God, he's up to like 20 now. He's up to like
20 failures.
All right. Like, there's just no way.
Freeze.
Yeah, you didn't see it. There's actually a ghost here. Okay.
This ghost just came and grabbed him and pulled him >> You
can just put your feet together with your heels touching. >> He
has to look back. Okay. >> Okay. And now put your arms
right down by your side. >> What? Who is that? Who the
[__] just did that? Okay. What?
Just grabbed my shoulder and pulled me >> And your arms
straight down by your side like this guy. >> Listen, this
guy's Haitian. He can move fast. It might have been him. Okay.
I suspect it was him. He looks like he was just standing there,
but I think he just tried he tried to hook hoodwink me. Okay,
I can see you. I can see you're fast. Thank you. All right, there
you go. So, he was touching arms straight down by your side.
You stay like that. Don't do anything else until I tell you to.
Do you understand so far? >> So, when I tell you to, I'm
going to tell you to raise one foot. You can choose the right
or the left. You're going to raise it approximately 6 in off
the ground. You're going to keep your foot parallel to the >> That
was That was what happened. Okay. When when he gave his license
over to these guys, the Haitian guy immediately pulled the hair
off of it and attached it to a voodoo doll. All right,
that's this guy's getting totally set up. Brown. And you're going
to look at the elevated foot while you count out loud in the
following manner. 1,00 1,002
1,003
1,004 and so on and so forth until I tell you to stop. Do you
understand the instructions so far? >> Okay. So again,
the way that it's going to look, your arms are straight down
by your side, your feet are together. I'm going to tell you to
begin and you're going to choose. You choose either your left
foot or your right foot. So, when I say begin, if you want to
pick up your left foot, you're going to pick it up about six
six inches off the ground. Again, keeping your foot parallel
to the ground while you keep your eyes on the elevated foot.
>> You understand that so far, Scott? Do you understand
the instructions, sir? >> I do. >> Okay. So, again,
the way that it's going to look, I'm going to show you one more
time. I'll do it with my right foot this time. I'm going to say
begin. You're going to raise your foot about 6 in off the ground.
It's about the size of a soda can. Okay? 6 in parallel to the
ground and your feet on the elevated foot. And you're going to
count out loud 100,00 1,0023
and so on and so forth until I >> He's got to have one
test. Okay. The lawyer for his DUI hearing needs at least one
field sobriety test that he passes so that they can make any
argument at all. Okay. This is the one moment he can save everything.
>> Tell you to stop. Do you understand all the instructions,
Scott? >> Okay, you may begin. 1000 one,00
two 100 300
>> It's not close. It's not close, man. He's not coming
close at all. Oh, I'm getting a drink really quickly. I'm going
to be like 10 seconds. Give me Give me a minute.
2 1 3 100 4
105 1006 Guys,
what the are we doing right now?
>> going back to the classics, guys. Are we really doing
this? What the are we doing here, guys? Aren't we being silly
right now? We're on the same team. We want the same things. Like,
Haitians out of America. Oh, wait. Let me look to my right. No,
never mind. Uh, Dominicans out of America. We want all the Dominicans
out of America. I'll get this Haitian guy on my side, right?
I just uh
>> Okay, Scott, can you be honest with me? How much did
you drink today? >> I had about four. >> Four what?
>> Okay. A drink to me is alcohol or is >> I have
not drank in several weeks.
>> You don't drink alcohol?
>> I have not drank alcohol in sever. Guys, don't [__]
me. >> Do you take any depressants?
>> I take medication because I'm a war vet. >> What
type of medication do you take, >> dude? Oh,
please.
Hold on. I I know exactly what's going on in this guy's I can
we we all know what's going on in this guy's head,
Hold on. Hold on. >> If you can hear us, please, Donald
Trump, please save me. >> What's going on, Donald Trump?
>> Internet internal monologue right now. >> I'm
asking.
Please save me.
Please save me. Please get these people away from me. >> In
dear God's name, please stop this >> Donald Trump, if you
can hear me right now, please. I I'm I'm one of your strongest
soldiers.
>> I don't know what this is called. >> Okay. Uh
does it say not to drive a vehicle when you're when you're >> No.
Lane. >> Do you take Xanax or anything like that? >> Do
you take any other type of drugs? >> Don't do this.
>> Scott, look man, your your eyes. You know what an estagmus
is. You told me >> Onset and estagmus. Yes. >> Okay.
The onset of Nstagmus prior to 45° is one of the
>> dude he's literally he by the way the onset of nestagmus
thing that he keeps saying all right that is that is just one
of the criteria for like letting somebody out of this but he
doesn't realize that he would just have nisagnus right that's
what that's what he would say if he had the medical condition
that could opt him out of the field sobriety test with the eyes
right I'm pretty sure that's like what he's trying to do right
now but he he keeps Not. He keeps saying onset of nisagnness.
Yeah. No. No.
>> Okay. Onset of noisagness prior to 45 degrees is one
of the one of the things.
>> Okay. But I really >> Oh, wait. No, no, no. That's
one of the things that uh maybe maybe that's when you fail if
you have nestagmas. Maybe if you get drunk enough. I don't think
I've ever been that drunk. >> They need to know what you
drink, where you drink at. Is that
>> we just got really lucky that he was too in self victimization
mode to realize that this Haitian guy might have just gone and
spoken to his kids. I think he he might have lost it if he realized
that happened. >> I don't know. I can't remember what the
[__] it's called.
>> No. Uh >> I've never been blind drunk.
The Yikes.
>> Was it a bar or restaurant or Oceanside?
>> It's all right, Scott. What What did you do there? >> I
had three drinks. >> Okay. What? What did you get?
>> You just said he hadn't drank in months like 90 seconds
ago. >> The bartender made it up. >> Was it like
a like a mixed drink or a
>> like whiskey, vodka, tequila, rum, gin. >> I don't
know. >> Okay. They don't know if it was like >> And
I have not drank in weeks. >> Did you eat anything today?
>> What did you eat? >> I made the boys some pancakes
>> this morning. >> Dinosaur pancakes. And what else
do we have? Um, >> well, thanks. Thankfully, Frenzy Freeze,
given his like total total victim mindset, his pointing out of
this guy being Haitian, like that was a problem for him, right?
He managed to make this go mega viral. Like this is viral all
over the place. So, his wife is definitely going to see it now.
>> Pancakes. That's the one.
>> Okay. All right. Scott, >> what have you had to
eat today? Dino pancakes. That's the one I remember.
Oh boy, that is not a good answer. He keeps giving a lot of really
bad answers. >> I need you to come back here with me, please.
I'm not going to do this in front of your kids, man. But you
got to come with me. I'm I'm not going to do it >> No,
you can put your hands back. >> If you're going to pull
away, then I'll do it in front of your kids. >> Okay. Don't
squeeze my hand. Let go. >> I'm not doing,
>> guys. I am law enforcement. >> Okay. I was going
to I was going to do this away from your kids, man. Going to
pull away from me, then I'll do it in front of them. >> I'm
not pulling away. I'm not [__] moving. Just relax.
Are you [__] kidding me right now, >> dude?
They wanted to let his this guy go. They wanted so badly for
this for just to be like, oh, you know, we misread it. Maybe
he was like getting with by his kids and he like let go of the
wheel. They wanted to let him go so
>> You have anything in your [__] mistake anything?
>> A few times has previously passed out of the playground.
Is there any reference to a white female? >> Well, sir,
I'm doing my job today. Guys, what are we doing here right now?
>> What are we even doing?
>> Try to keep your hands turned the way that I have this
one. Your your left hand right now. >> Okay, try to get
this.
go on the left side,
Lane,
why? >> Lane. Lane, what do we even got? Lane, really?
You're going to do this to me, >> Run of my kids. >> It's
uh it's clear to the right.
>> you can go to my hood. >> God damn it. >> Just
right up against my hood, sir. Do you have anything on you that's
going to hurt us? >> [__] no, man.
>> I just If I Listen, we're going to have to start uh
here. This is what we're going to do. If he says if he says something
like Guys, what are we even doing here? We're going to have to
Okay. each time now. From now on. >> So, Scott, unfortunately,
right now, you are under the in uh you are under arrest for uh
driving under the influence.
>> Scott, I believe you're impaired.
>> Guys, don't do this.
>> I believe you're too impaired. >> Nah. Nah. >> Operate
motor vehicle safely. Scott.
One custody.
>> I do not have anything.
We're going to go to the capacitor
lane.
White. What about my kiss? We're We're going to have to figure
that out next. >> Damn it. Lane, do you have any shield
back there?
>> Dude, this is uh he didn't break out this tactic earlier.
This is one of those things. He's trying to humanize you to the
other person, right? You know their name. Lane, why? Lane, why
are we doing this? Lane, why? Lane, >> guys, please. I
am going through a
Don't do this to me.
Scott, are you able to fit in there? Lane.
We wear the same.
>> Dude, that's the best way he could say we're both law
enforcement. Listen, Lane, we wear the same [__]
Lane, we wear the same [__] How could you do >> Lane?
Just talk to me for a minute. All right. I got you, man. But
I really need you to get it, please. >> I get it.
Cuz man, what the divorce?
Cuz Lane, come on, man.
This is going to me, dude. Please don't do this to me. >> I
got arrested for DY 2 years ago. >> Lane, I get it. But
do you have kids? >> Own up to your mistakes, man. You're
you're you're a grown adult. I cried my ass off, too. Own up
to it. You're going to sit in jail tonight. It's going to suck.
>> Are you serious? >> You're going to It's going
to suck, man.
did you hear me? Lane, I'm crying. Lane, they're taking my kids.
>> It sucked for me. It's going to suck for you, too. It
is. >> Could he hit another octave? Could he get an octave
higher? >> What it is? Be a man. Suck it up. That's what
everyone tells us. I know. I get it. Whatever. If you're a cop,
whatever. >> Yeah. I'm I'm law enforcement. >> Okay,
dude. Then stop talking and sit in the back of the car and stop.
Stop this. >> Let's go. >> Stop this. >> What
about my kids? >> We're gonna take care of you. >> No,
I'm not going in there.
>> Let me talk to your supervisor.
They do have to get a family member to come pick up the kids,
which obviously pretty much guarantees the wife's going to find
out about it. >> Again, you can talk to him in a second.
>> They didn't call her. >> Not going in there without
my supervisor. Okay, let's go to the other side. Come on. Come
on, man. Don't pull against me. What's going on? >> I'm
not moving. >> Bro, don't do this.
come on back. >> Now, here's the real trick, guys. We need
to go find Okay. Two years ago, DUI
uh Florida State Patrol. Okay, we need to go find this guy. We
need to see. We need to review. Okay, how much better did Lane
perform under pressure? Can we find the body cam footage? Can
we foyer this? All right, I need to figure out how much better
did Lane do under pressure. He cried, but did he cry to the officers?
Did he say, "Guys, we're same team. Same team. Don't do this
to me, guys." How close was it?
>> So, you guys are [__]
>> Come on. Put your feet in. >> Stand up. Stand
up. Come on. Stand up. Put your feet in. No. be a kid. Come on.
>> Where are my kids? >> Stand up. Put your feet
in. >> What? Put your feet in. Put your feet >> You
don't want to make this worse. All right. Do you >> Come
on. Come on, man. Let's go. You got to sit in the car. >> You're
going to jail for DUI with misdemeanor. If you don't cooperate,
you go to jail for resistance. It only makes it worse. >> Come
on. Put your feet in, buddy. >> All right. Your kids will
be fine. They're full. >> Listen to me. >> Don't
sign the left. Come on. Let's go. We We got to sit. >> God
damn you guys. Thank you. Okay. Dwayne, you really me, man. >> I
didn't you, man. I'm not the one that drank today and drove
>> Oh, I got down to two. We got We We went from four to
three. He got down to two by the end. All right.
>> You got this deal.
>> What are you doing, man?
>> Don't suck with my kids, man. >> I'm not messing
with your kids. >> They're They're going to go with their
mother for tonight. They're just going to go sit at the station.
Their mom's driving down to pick them up. >> God damn it.
Look, >> I guess you're mad, man. But don't take it out
on me. >> I didn't take a [__] out on you,
man. >> Well, you told me a few times you hate me and said,
"Go [__] myself." >> I didn't. >> Yeah,
you did. >> No, I didn't. >> Look, man. I'm not trying
to be hard on you. I was trying to be a to you. You said it when
I first pulled you over. I'm just doing my job. This pays the
bills. This is my job.
It is what it is, man. I can't say no to it. You're
>> What can you do, buddy? It is what it is. That's how
the cookie crumbles. All right. You know, you win some, you lose
some. Please keep keep showering this guy in platitudes. I'm
sure it's going to make him feel better. Lane, >> it is
what it is, man. >> Let me see my kids. >> Brother,
I really do not want them to see you in the way that you're in
right now. Right now, they're fine. They think dad's chill. He's
just going to go hang out with us for a few hours. >> No,
they don't. Guys, >> they do. Lane,
>> I'll be cool.
We can't We can't do that right now,
>> [__] with me. >> I'm not bringing
your kids over here on the side of the road. I'm not putting
them over there. I >> Let me go see them. >> We can't
do that right now, Scott. >> We can't do that, man. >> Everything
will be fine, man. You just go for the night. You Everything
will be cool off and then >> go for the night.
>> Oh, boy. I I am physically cringing just watching this
guy try to talk to the the ICE agent who immediately identified
his Haitian accent. Oh boy. Oh god. >> Everything will
be fine, man. You should go for the night. Everything will be
pull off and then >> go for the night >> and tomorrow
you'll be you know >> dude really really just think you
got to calm down. You got to calm down. >> Oh, but I want
to see my kids. >> I got you. But you got to calm down.
I promise you.
Unhook me. Let me just go see my boys, man. >> Cannot do
that, Scott. >> God damn you, Lane. >> I'm sorry.
>> Please, Lane. >> All right, man. You don't have
anything else on you, right? All right, >> am just let
me know. Just so you know, this is still on. >> Bro, he
aged like I know it's the resolution, but he gets closer. He
aged like 10 years during that car ride in the the field sobriety
tests. He did not look that old standing in the back of his truck
and then out of nowhere he's just like ancient. >> We're
going to go to uh the pink door over here. >> No, it was
a fantastic body cam video. Hold on. I've also got the uh the
police or sorry, I've got the news story here that goes with
this. Okay, let's check this out. This was how far back? August
is when this actually got um got put out. But I think we just
got the body cam footage like today, right?
Is that >> us please? Donald Trump. >> Wrong one.
Wrong video. Hold on. This was uh 16th of October. Yesterday
the body cam footage came out. So Monroe County, Florida, Florida
man who claimed he was an US Immigration and Customs Enforcement
agent was arrested after being accused of driving drunk behind
the wheel with two small children in his car. According to Monroe,
the Monroe County Sheriff's Office, MS MCSO, deputies pulled
over Scott Deseroth Deseroth of Miami at around 3:24 p.m. on
Wednesday after receiving a report of a motorist driving recklessly
near mile marker, mile marker 40. The sheriff's office says before
the traffic stop was initiated, deputies saw Deseroth, 42, driving
into oncoming traffic and swerving heavily. Deputies were able
to stop the vehicle near mile marker 36.5.
Jesus Christ.
Short meme. Hold on. What's the What's the crisp meme? Let's
check it out real
>> Hey, what do you think you were doing back there? Get
out. >> I just made a mistake. I'm sorry. >> You're
too right you did. >> Oh god.
>> Hey, get off the road. >> Hey, this guy's got
some pretty heavy going on in his life right now. Okay, just
give us a break. >> Really?
Really? >> Move it. Hey. >> Oh, is this is this what
he thought was going to happen? I'm getting divorced. They're
trying to take my kids. This is what he thought was going to
happen, >> A break, will you? This guy's going through
some serious [__] My guess is his wife just left
him. >> Oh, Christ.
Same thing happened to me. >> Yeah, tell me about it, brother.
>> Hey, Colin. There's a bloke up here. His wife's just
run off with the kids. Do you know how much that hurts? >> Hey,
I'm hurting, too. My whole life's pretty well passed me by, and
I got nothing to show for it.
I dread going to work every day. I try it so hard and the boss
treats me like >> I feel sick all the time. I pretend to
be cool and together but inside I hate myself. Hey, I haven't
spoken to my father, Fate. Yes. Yeah, this is getting way too
real way too fast. Thank you very much for the meme, Chris. This
is what he thought. He thought he was going to get this empathy.
Okay, didn't happen. He didn't see it. All right,
let's continue on here. When deputies made contact with Desroth,
they observed two small children in the car, ages seven and nine,
and detected a strong odor of alcohol coming from him. Deputies
say Desroth allegedly misidentified his location and gave a wrong
direction of travel. After failing the standardized field exercises,
Desroth was taken to the Monroe County Jail. The sheriff's office
says the children in the vehicle were turned over to a family
member and the Florida Department of Children and Families was
notified. Desroth was booked on DUI and child endangerment. by
the way, two ch two charges of felony child endangerment for
this guy. Okay, so he's not getting off the hook. He is not going
to see his kids again for a while. Uh it's it's kind of over.
All right, it's kind of over.
Also,
now that we've capped that off,
uh charged with DUI, first-degree misdemeanor, resisting officer
without violence, first-degree misdemeanor, and child neglect,
third degree felony. I believe two charges of child neglect watching
you back. Also, guys, we're going to hop off of Twitch. Thank
you very much. If you've been watching on Twitch, we're going
to head over to kick for the rest of the stream. Thank you for,
you know, all the Twitch viewers. If somebody could throw the
kick link in the Twitch chat, I'd appreciate it. And we're going
to head over there now. So, good luck, Twitchers. We'll see you
in just a little bit. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
All right. His wife his wife did just win. Okay. Massive W for
her, I guess. I don't know. Maybe she cares about him and just
wanted him to get healthy. I don't know. Sometimes people have
to hit rock bottom, man. Like, you can't just let a guy go who's
swerving around
like swerving around through traffic apparently driving into
oncoming traffic with his kids in the car, right? Like that is
rock bottom. That has to be rock bottom. You can't let them off
the hook after that. Are you going to be responsible for the
for when he kills his kids or somebody else's kids driving drunk
like this or do you want him to get help now? Like this is the
best thing for him. This is showing mercy. This is taking this
guy and putting his best interest forward, right? arresting him
now, getting him charged, getting him in treatment. This is just
the only thing you can do for somebody who's in the state.
Okay. All right.
that's pretty that's pretty crazy, dude. It's pretty nuts. Monroe
County Sheriff's Office public records request. What is this?
Accelerate. Hold on. What is this?
Just link. Marmadude said,
"Do we all really know who the bad guy is here?
Can I go up to this please?
No. Okay. Well, never mind. What was this? The human made concern.
Pursuant to this, I hereby request the following records. Request
access to copies of all of this
for this guy's charges. This is in
Wait, what?
Oh. To the arrest of Deputy Jonathan Michael Lane on Oh, I see
what you're saying. was found off duty to sleep at the wheel
of his personal vehicle at a gas station around 2 a.m. Subsequently
arrested for DUI and placed on administrative leave.
Oh, somebody was doing this in
Why is somebody doing this back here? Apparently, somebody has
gone and looked for it
with the videos. No way.
Okay, but we don't know that this is the lane guy, do we? Can
we figure out who this is? Do we know that this is the
Oh my god. Do we just have this straight up? Bro, there's no
way we just have this straight up. Do we? Let's go. Sunshine
law. That's crazy.
What?
Hold on. I I pulled this off screen, but I mean, if it's just
in a Dropbox link, dude, what? Hold on. Let's uh let's start
clicking through some of these.
This is in car. Is this him sleeping in his car,
Or is this him back here?
Can we hear the voice? We got a voice when he gets in. Okay.
That right here is where he goes and gets put in a car. Oh, that
just clicked me through videos. [__] me. Hold on.
I don't know. I've never used this site before. Give me Be patient.
Okay. I have autism.
Here we go.
That's him breathing, by the way. >> Can you leave the
seat belt off, please? I'm a grown adult. I don't need a seat
belt in the back seat. If I crash, it's on me.
>> Okay. I can't tell if that's the same guy. How could
we figure out the arresting officers from this case? I think
we could, right? Hold on. I think we could. One second. Cuz I
don't know if this is actually him. Do we know for sure if that's
him? Cuz I would love to see if he does any field sobriety tests
or anything like this here. This is the one video. Let me check.
Let me check. This appears to be like the body cam footage we'd
want, right? Them walking up to the vehicle or something. Oh,
come on. Don't be muted the whole time. So, it's Monroe County
Sheriff's Office Deputy Lane >> with the two videos before
the blurred extraction. Okay. Okay. Okay. These ones. All right.
Okay. They walk up, look into his vehicle. He just going along.
Okay. >> One Sierra. >> Oh, there's no way that's
an open container, is there?
>> bro. He doesn't Did he just not wake up when the when
the car door gets opened? Is there like no indication he's waking
up right here? Oh, boy.
Like to be to be that [__] up that you don't even
you don't even move.
>> Yikes. Back to his car.
Go back up here. Okay.
Listen, just to cap it off, I feel like we we asked for this.
We wanted to take a look. >> I felt sick when I was >> Oh,
here we go.
All right. >> Did you work today?
>> Yeah. Dies. >> Come on. Speak up for me, buddy.
Is this Jonathan? Apparently, this is Jonathan Lane. Yes. >> Where
are you coming from?
>> I saw you.
>> Uh, I went to a girl's house in uh Summerland. I I got
that felt sick. >> That could be him. I'm listening. Apparently,
we've got another video of him arresting somebody else, too.
>> Listen to his voice. >> Can't drive that slow
under the speed limit. I work here, >> guys. Look,
>> I'm SFSD certified.
>> Okay, so am I. I'm a drug recognition expert. Okay,
fantastic. Good for you. I need your driver's license for what?
>> get out of the car. >> Oh, this is what we need
to look at, right? The tattoos. Do we have the tattoos on the
guy? Uh, in this Yeah. Yeah, we got a sleeve. Left arm sleeve
right here. Hold on. Wait, did I just [__] something
up? No, no, no. We're good. Uh, we're looking for when he comes
over here, does he have a sleeve on his left arm? Would we be
able to see that while he's doing his body cam [__]
>> Oh, you might not be able to see it on his body cam
[__] >> They don't Are you diabetic?
Okay,
>> you understand? >> Yep. Are you diabetic?
>> Are you epileptic? >> Check when he's putting
him in the car. Good point. Uh, this is Hold on. I just saw an
arm here.
There's this arm. This is his other arm, though. On Do you understand?
>> That's uh he's got long sleeves on. We might not be
able to see it at all here.
>> Really need to get it. >> Get the full extension
of the left arm here. Hold on. Points. Points. Where's he pointing?
Wait, I just saw the full extension of the left arm. What
>> Okay, it's somewhere here. >> Scott able to fit
in there.
>> Right there. >> Don't do this to me. >> Right
there. >> Are you able to fit in there? >> Oh, he's
There's no way we're going to see it, right? He's got the watch
and the long sleeves. 2811. You can see the top of it. What?
You can see the top of it. Looks He's got a sleeve here for sure.
Left arm got a sleeve. Okay, listen. I think I think this is
the guy then. This is our guy. And we've got another arrest from
Jonathan Lane here. This is the the saga of Jonathan Lane. Let's
go. >> You're sick? >> Well, I I felt sick when I
was there. I I didn't sleep much yesterday. So, last night I
thrown up a lot.
I don't know if I food poison or what the hell wrong with me,
but I'm still >> Okay, apparently apparently this isn't
that good, right? Like appar somebody click through it. Apparently
he's just going to go with him. He just tells him his story and
>> you medication. >> No, don't go anywhere.
>> Smelling alcohol?
>> Got a mosquito on your face. You You killed it. Guy
just hit himself in the >> I'd like to think there's no
mosquito there and this guy just with his partner all the time.
You got a mosquito in your face, buddy. Black. >> Yeah.
Check him out. >> Yeah. I I I don't want to make sure he's
I don't smell
>> Okay. If you don't smell any alcohol and he doesn't
he's not on any medications. What the [__] going
on? >> I guess fentanyl some kind of some kind of drugs.
Probably not. >> But he's the one that created it. Not
>> We'll speed through. We'll see if there's anything interesting
going on
>> You feel sick now?
>> Oh, hold on.
Oh, but this this sleeve doesn't go quite as low as the other
one. Okay, it's not really a sleeve then, but whatever this is,
it doesn't go quite as low. So, left arm, it goes down to the
>> We called to come check you out.
>> Conor would banging on your windows like to the point
to break them and you still weren't responsive. Had to open your
door and give you a sternal rub. Still not responsive. >> Is
that a snake? I think one of these was Medusa for sure. I think
the other arm he had like some uh some pale woman. I I thought
I thought it was like a Medusa basically in his other arm. >> You
armed?
>> No. Did you think you were like Is there a firearm missing?
>> No. The way you just felt your waist made me think you
like Oh, maybe. Yeah. >> Dude, uh unfortunately for us,
it appears
that our good friend, Officer Lane, Johnny boy, here, he's too
up to even cry or make excuses right now. He's just telling them
the truth. He's just like, "Yeah, I'm man." So, he is handling
it a lot better, but it's also it's also cuz he's like out of
his mind right now, right?
I'm just speed it up here. Try to get through it real quick.
>> Back over. Oh, this the scrub's pretty good on this.
I shouldn't have to wait around. Look like they're about to talk
though.
Go back to the vehicle.
>> Go back to the vehicle. They're like,
>> bro, really? It feels like that probably should have
been censored. No,
>> hold on. I want to see. Is that this guy trying to get
a hold of somebody or is this guy taking his phone and trying
to find someone who could pick Lane up? Oh no, you're just Okay.
Well, listen. Florida should do a better job of helping these
people. What?
>> Did you catch it? I caught that he had like a game there.
Hold on. Hold on. What else did he have there?
Hold on. Do we need to Do we need to slow roll through this?
What apps did he have open? Dude, he's playing slots. Was that
slots or was that just like candy?
Is that slots or is that just like some game on the phone that
like whatever version of your
>> I can't tell. >> Oh, dude. That would be really
That would be really funny to slow it down and find the is Candy
Crush. Okay, got it. Slow it down and find the Asmin Gold tab.
Just going to review this guy's phone now. >> Is he getting
checked out? This should definitely be
This should definitely be uh
>> Okay, they got an ambulance here.
God, hold on. >> You have a odor of alcohol. Don't answer.
I can smell myself.
>> Oh. Uh, they're trying to help this guy out, aren't
they? Is that what that question was? Oh, did did you smell the
odor of alcohol? Never mind. Don't answer. Like don't put that
on the body >> That wasn't the officer's phone. We saw
the name and pray for it. Oh, sorry. It was the officer's phone.
>> Your car keys. You want us to park your
friends. I'm going to put the car on the side of the thing here.
>> See, he's got the history receipt. Yeah.
>> He said, "Don't answer. I can smell it myself." But
earlier in the video, he said he couldn't smell alcohol at all.
So, that's the thing.
>> Little slow. I get
checked out. >> He said I could smell it myself, but he
also said earlier on
Oh, we Yeah, we watched this on stream, Chris. This was pretty
funny when this happened. the guy who's like who rolls up with
the Yasmin Gold VOD playing and then they they get to the firefight.
This is pretty crazy. >> Sometimes people might just have
opposite perspectives on things that aren't informed by some
sort of
>> stay in the car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, XQC's reaction, too. Dude, I I remember
this. I remember going through this. This was some funny stuff.
Hold on, let me check. Uh,
it's going to pop up. It will. Dude, the mirror is just going
to be faster. Hold on. Let me click through the mirror. Here
we go. >> Let's go into Asmin Gold before a shootout. What?
What?
What? Huh? >> What?
What? >> It's safe.
It's crazy how well it's clipped together just to show like the
Asigold. Not even clipped together. It's like right back to back.
He's literally listening to Asigold. He gets out. He's firing
shots within 10 seconds.
>> That's insane. H >> things that aren't informed
by some sort of foreign power. >> Stay in the cars.
>> What the >> Oh, you stop. >> Things that
aren't informed by some sort of foreign power. >> Stay
in the cars.
Watch that. How's How's it >> Oh, he didn't even watch.
Yeah, the guy gets out and starts firing shots
Oh boy. Okay, I think we're done. Are we done with Mr. Lane?
Officer Lane here. There is one other There is one other video
with him. The secret history of the bad cop who arrested a brain
damaged driver being for being too slow. Oh, wait. Never mind.
We are going to watch this, bro. This is lane. This is lane.
The secret history of the bad cop who arrested a brain damaged
driver for being too slow.
We got to watch this, right? Like wallto-wall lane tent. I think
so. I'm sorry. I can't I can't let you guys. I understand some
people might want to get on to other piece of content tonight,
but I can't I can't look away. We got to
Officer Lane apparently arrested a >> I saw you going 15
miles an hour. Okay, that's not legal. You can't drive that slow
under the speed limit. >> I work here. >> Okay, fantastic.
Good for you. I need your driver's license >> for what?
>> get out of the car. Get out of the car. >> Unlock
the car and get out now. Calm >> Get out of the car now.
>> Calm down. I am out. It's absolutely outrageous the
way this police officer treats this >> context again. Which
one was Lane? Lane was the arresting officer speaking to to the
guy, the ICE officer, right? Most of the time. So the most of
the time the ICE officer is addressing officer Lane. This Lane
guy said, "I got arrested for DUI 2 years ago. We just watched
Lane's DUI arrest from 2 years ago." And now we're going on to
another video that involves Officer Jonathan Lane in Monroe County
again, which is him. Apparently, somebody made a video, the civil
rights lawyer, the civil rights lawyer.com,
about this guy who arrested someone for driving too slowly. Although,
I think that's a fair arrest. So, I don't understand what the
what the violation is here. I mean, just because you're brain
damage doesn't mean you can make everybody else on the road unsafe.
Driving too slow is super dangerous. >> This guy who has
a traumatic brain >> my husband has a traumatic brain injury,
so his ability to process information and respond effectively
is impaired. This cop is a real stickler for the rules. I mean,
the law is the law, >> The brain injury, that sucks. I'm
very sorry for you and your family. He cannot touch me. He cannot
refuse orders that I give to him. >> Except when it comes
to himself. This is the same cop in custody in the county he
works in after being arrested unconscious behind the wheel. >> Dude,
what the [__] Not even We're not even the first Alogs
down this road. We're not even the first people logging officer
Lane.
That's crazy.
That's insane. Sheriff's office. >> The footage is extremely
damning. When I went to look up the resolution of that case,
guess what? The record is confidential. Here's a prime example
of >> Oh, I bet you this is the guy who actually applied
for the records, right? I bet you this is the guy who did the
foyer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Private Huff, I bet you
this is the guy who did who foyed the records in March to actually
get all of the videos. politicians and prosecutors and law enforcement
leadership protecting a bad apple and endangering the public.
>> You armed?
>> No. Did you think you were?
>> Like a Is there a firearm missing? >> And now
it's time for everybody to know the truth. Let's >> I'm
pretty sure he goes, "Uh, no." To be fair, kind of clip chimp
there. Okay. He goes, "Uh, no." It's not the best response, but
it's not like, "Uh." And he just looks around dumbly >> again.
As both a content creator and a lawyer, I can assure you that
your private data is being collected and traded online by shady
data brokers who then create shadow profiles on you that include
a frightening amount of personal details. Your private info is
then used without your knowledge. >> Oh no, even less,
you do need to foil this stuff. And this was foyed with this
guy specifically in mind. >> Or consent by insurance companies,
businesses, banks, and even the government. Do do we know is
this guy aware that this this same cop is
I just wonder if he'd be aware that the same cop just made this
arrest this recent arrest
3 days ago. Apparently not. I I just thought maybe he'd keep
tabs on him to see. It's an interesting channel. How often what
do you guys think the rate is? Okay. What percentage of his videos
do you think are from Florida? You think it's above or below
50% for this channel? If this guy just reviews like body I feel
like it's above 50%.
It got it's got to be right. The sunshine laws plus
just crazy. It's Florida way above. Okay. All right. Keep >> That's
why I use a product called Incogn that not only tracks down these
data brokers that have your information, but they have that data
completely removed. Even for me, it would take hundreds of hours
of my time to do this myself. Incogn does it for me, continuously
working in the background. As of today, Incogn has located my
private data with 586
different data brokers, and they have now had that data deleted
with 547
of those data brokers with 39 others by trailering a boat or
driving too slow. Over a minor traffic violation, he begins issuing
him orders and then yanks him out of his truck when he doesn't
comply quickly enough.
>> Hello. Hi, I'm Deputy L with the sheriff's office. How
can I? >> Uh, so we got called to Sunshine Key about you
and then on the way up there I saw you going 15 miles an hour
>> and a hazard on there, right? >> Okay, that's
not legal. You can't do >> Can't do what? >> You
can't drive that slow under the speed limit. >> It's a
safety hazard. >> It's a safety hazard for you to be on
>> Listen, sir. You've broken the law by doing this. And
he's like, you're right. It's a safety hazard for somebody to
do that. That's really bad. Nobody should do that. >> Road
driving that slow under the speed limit. Correct. Do you have
your driver's license on? >> Sir, I need to get to this
lane. Can you get it off this? I work here. >> Okay, fantastic.
Good for you. I need your driver's license >> for what?
>> get out of the car. Get out of the car. >> Unlock
the car and get out now. Calm >> Get out of the car now.
>> Calm down. I am out. >> You You want You want
to stop and grab?
>> Oh [__] My truck. My truck. You a truck
in the park. >> Yes, I am. >> Put it in a park now.
What happened? So, it seems like Officer Lane went a little too
hard here. Okay. This is not This is not great. But I also see
it seems like we cut in pretty late into the stop, right? Like
I want to see before this cuz obviously like lane's escalating
now, but I need to see before. Is this coming out of nowhere?
Cuz it looks like it comes out of nowhere,
right? Is it coming out of nowhere or
>> put it into park now? is in part. I am >> left
three code four one resistant. >> I am not. >> Yeah,
you're right. I don't even know. Is it possible
>> cuz like
>> he did walk up and go, you were driving too slow. That's
why I pulled you over.
>> Turn around. Put your hands behind your back. Now put
your hands behind your Put your hands. Stop pulling away from
me.
23 code 51
the other way.
nervous. Cannot spin it. >> Do you have anything on you
that's going to stick me, poke me, hurt me? >> Uh, one
pocket knife. >> Your pocket knife. >> Oh man, dude.
That makes me think of weapons. You guys watch weapons, right?
Couple people, have you guys seen weapons where you ask the guy
like, "You have anything in your pockets that's going to poke
me?" And the guy goes, "No, no, no, no, no. I don't." He's got
like heroin needles in there and the guy immediately pokes his
hand. Gh.
Like that's the most horrifying part of that movie for me is
that guy. Well, that that one but then later with the needles
as well. But that dude, the needle stuff that Okay, that is up.
There's a clip. I don't even know if I can find it. >> I'm
good for now.
>> If you if you can talk to her inside of the car. >> Why
is she being rude? >> I'm not sure.
>> Why is she being rude, too? because I'm a law enforcement
officer and so is she and I have you in handcuff right now. >> Okay,
but no need to be rude is >> I got FWC with me as well.
So in the state of Florida when you're told to identify yourself
on a traffic stop by law enforcement >> I did >> saying
no when I say give me your driver's license is not comping
>> Yes, it is on recording. >> Just like when I told
you to step out of the car and you said no. I tried to >> Uhoh.
Dude, there's no way. Are we really getting I got to Hold on.
I got to open it again because listen, I maybe I wasn't paying
close enough attention right off the bat here when he first walks
up and I I need to be paying better attention cuz >> over
a minor traffic violation. >> We got called to >> Hello.
Hi.
>> Do we not have any cuts here? Cuz it didn't seem like
he gave him a lot of time, right? Yeah. How can I help? >> Uh,
so we got called to Sunshine Key about you and then on the way
up there I saw you going 15 m an hour >> and with my hazards
on, correct? >> Okay, that's not legal. You can't do >> Can't
do. >> Okay. With my hazards on. Correct. >> You
can't drive that slow under the speed limit. >> It's a
safety hazard. >> It's a safety hazard for you to be on
the road driving that slow under >> Okay. Now
I get what I get. I think he's trying to say like I have my hazards
on because it's a safety hazard, but I think I should be allowed
to do it. >> The speed limit. Correct. Do you have your
driver's license on? >> Sir, I need to get to this landing.
Can we get it off this? I work here. >> Okay, fantastic.
Good for you. I need your driver's license. >> For what?
>> Okay. So, it wasn't a no. It was a for
And if if there's anything I know about cops, maybe you guys
have some experience with this, too. Cops will take like tone
as like 9/10en of the you're saying like if you could say if
you could smile. Well, apparently Kerski they're saying it was
shared with pedestrians and bicycles. So there were cyclists
on this road too. So the speed limit couldn't have been that
high, right? You saying 45 or 55? 15 and uh >> we got called
to Sunshine Key about you and then on the way >> but that
that like for what he would I could just see him getting set
off >> up there. I saw you going 15 miles an >> and
a hazard on direct. >> Okay, that's not legal. You can't
do >> Can't do what? >> You can't drive that slow
under the speed limit. >> It's a safety hazard. >> It's
a safety hazard for you to be on the road driving that slow under
the speed limit. Correct. Do you have your driver's license on?
>> Sir, I need to get to this landing. Can you get it off
this?
>> It's a safety hazard.
zone. Correct.
>> There. Uh, so we got called to Sunshine Key about you
and then on the way up there I saw you going 15 m an hour >> and
you jump right
>> sounded like 50 55. Yeah. Okay. All >> Open your
door. >> Um, so that's all we needed from that part. Okay.
They uh he got short. He got real short. The for what kind of
throw him off. It didn't seem like the guy was asking for that
much either. He was saying, "Hey, I work just up the road. Can
I pull in there?" I think cops don't like you doing this, but
to me, I don't understand why. I guess it it implies they're
going to let you get back in the vehicle, right? They might be
concerned you're impaired in some way, and it lets you get back
in the vehicle. Maybe that. What's up, Wendy? How's it going?
But it's it does seem like it would make sense to get further
ahead. You can eat your drugs. Yeah, sure. There could be a lot
of reasons they don't want you to move, like after they make
a stop. >> Door, you grabbed my hand and pushed me away.
That's bad law enforcement.
That's exactly what I was doing. >> You grab my hand. That's
felony. >> Oh my god. I was trying to put >> after
he throws them in the back of >> Okay, so the cops and
the cops saying that's probably a little too aggressive,
right? But I don't I think as long as they don't actually arrest
the guy for this, if they arrested this guy for it, okay, which
listen, the title does say they arrested him.
Uh you should let this go. You should definitely I think you
should the police cruiser. He then goes and talks to the man's
wife who explains to him that her husband had been in a motorcycle.
>> By the way, with this video getting made, I think I
can understand why Lane was so much nicer to the other cop there,
right? I feel like he probably has been told like, "Hey, no more
of this nonsense with you being like a straightup [__]
to people you pull >> And we can't handle another video.
>> Suffered a traumatic brain injury and as a result, his
cognitive functioning abilities are impaired. >> Hello.
Is there anyone else inside the >> My children and our
his service dog.
>> My husband has a traumatic brain injury, so his ability
to process information and respond effectively
is impaired. I was going to try to see. I think >> Oh,
she's being Dude,
she's being so calm, too. This makes him look so much worse,
right?
Like,
objectively, he just kind of yanked that dude out of the car
and threw him in the back of the cruiser. And she's being so
calm and nice even though that happened and just trying to explain.
Listen, he's got a traumatic brain injury. Like this is he he
probably can't understand all that. Well, dude, I feel like this
is in Florida, right? This be in Florida again. I feel like for
American woman, Florida, you just arrested her husband. The fact
that she's not hurling like I don't know, hurling garbage at
you right now. Like, hold on. Arrested in front of kids, too.
>> Yeah, the kids are in the car. Yeah. Like I the fact
that she's not freaking out right now and she's remaining calm
is crazy. I >> think his wallet is here in the boat. I
was going to grab it. He has a brain injury card. I am his legal
caregiver in addition to being his spouse. We are volunteering
here at the park and it just became stressful because
>> So the problem though is that when I tell someone to
give me their ID and they say no, that's refusal to identify.
>> Did he say no? >> He said no. He did have the
legal obligation to provide his driver's license to the police
officer during the stop. But the big question here is whether
or not he refused to do so. >> Problem though is that when
I tell someone to give me their ID and they say >> That's
refusal to identify. >> Did he say no? >> He said
no. >> When we look back at the footage, does it show that
the driver refused to provide his ID? >> I work here. >> Okay,
fantastic. Good for you. I need your driver's license. >> For
what?
>> Get out of the car. Get out of the car. unlock the car
and get out. >> No, I don't think that it does.
>> No, he was not. And then when I tell him to open the
door and he says no, that's again refusing an order from Hold
on, I'm talking. That's refusal. >> Dude, he is Lane's
having a bad day today on this one. This is October of 2024.
Dude, he is being anse people. >> Ident to identify himself
and refusal to exit the vehicle, which is an order from law enforcement
officer. And does the footage show that the driver refused to
get out of the vehicle? >> Now, calm down. >> Get
out of the car now. >> Calm down. I am out. >> No,
I don't think that does either. >> Furthermore, when I
reach inside the car to unlock the door and he grabs my hand,
that's felony battery on law
Fourth, when I do finally get the car door open and he pushes
me away, that's battery on law enforcement. He cannot touch me.
Okay. It I don't I don't The brain injury that sucks. I'm very
sorry for you and your family. He cannot touch me. He cannot
refuse orders that I give to him. This illegal, lawful traffic
stop. He's impeding the flow of traffic going 10 miles an hour
on US1. You cannot do that.
>> Okay. We're we're very concerned about impeding the
flow of traffic. Very Listen, this is the worst thing you could
do. Impede the flow of traffic. >> He is correct. It is
a safety hazard to do that. >> Gas boat and truck. >> That's
why I pulled him over. He can't do that.
>> Okay. I apologize. Like I said, his response and his
ability to know what to say in stressful moments is in here.
>> Dude, this wife is absolutely lame, too. By the way,
the She's so calm. She's so understanding of like him not getting
it right. She's She's so calm that this like makes him look so
much worse in response. Now,
>> he has missing pieces of his brain like that. I'm like
going to >> How old are the kids in the car? >> Uh
7 minutes. >> Okay. Can you go back in the car and make
sure they're okay? >> Yeah, absolutely. >> What are
you doing back here? >> I was going to see if this wallet
is in
>> Want me to grab his >> Yes, please. If you could.
Thank you. All right. I'm going to open the door for a second
and talk to you, >> but I don't want you to try to get
out or do anything. Okay. >> Uh he did rip the guy out
and the car was in drive. I believe it's standard practice to
like park the car. You put the vehicle in park as soon as you're
pulled over. You can't have the vehicle in drive. You're supposed
to park hit like you're supposed to immediately park the vehicle.
They might tell you to shut the vehicle off, too. I feel like
when I've been pulled over, they do tell you to shut the vehicle
off. Like, hey, the ignition like right. I I don't know. That's
That's what I remember. You didn't say that. You might not have.
>> And then your wife.
>> Not sure. Look, I am very I was not trying to be combative.
I have a slow
>> She explain She explained that to me. Okay. All of a
sudden, I realized I'm not an arc and I'm I wasn't trying to
resist you. I was trying to let you, but yet and then we get
out. When he finally got out, I promise you I was not trying.
I did not hear how now you could Do you think is this
I'm almost sitting here like, is this a is this a a meme? Is
this like a bet? I have a slow
thinking
>> and I'm I wasn't trying to resist, >> dude. Hold
on. I got to >> Yes, sir. Actually, look, I am very I was
not trying to be combative. I have a slow thinking. >> She
explain She explained that to me. >> I have a slow thinking.
>> All of a sudden, I realized I'm not in park and I'm
I wasn't trying to resist you. I was trying to let you, but yet
and then we get out. When it finally got out, I promise you,
I was not trying to resist. Like, >> I understand why you
got back in the truck. That was probably for the best. Since
you have kids in the car, >> I'm very So, I know I I've
worked in the fire my whole life and I know exactly what y'all
go through at that moment. >> I know exactly.
>> When you see me trying to jump back in,
I want to thank you the highest for not pulling that trigger
when I jumped back in. I know when the adrenaline starts. >> Thank
you. Thank you, officer. Thank you for not shooting me in the
face.
>> Oh my gosh. Yes.
>> My adrenaline was pumping. >> So So the main problem
that I have though is you grabbed my hand and you pushed my arms
away. You >> I believe he identified himself as somebody
who was in the fire department when he first got pulled over.
He says, "I work at the fire department. I'm about to pull into
work. Could you let us get up there or something like that?"
>> Cannot do that. >> I didn't mean to push you away.
I was trying to to assure you that here you have my hand, but
let me reach with the other hand and but I I can't think of how
to say it.
My adrenaline was pumping and I'm just like, here's one, but
let me Okay, >> I I really I swear to you, I I've worked
I want to join y'all so bad. I swear to you on God's hand, I
put God all over my life. Ever since my accident, I swear to
you, I was not trying to resist. I put my life in God's hand
on that script.
>> Dude, Lane,
it's not looking good for Lane. Okay, we were we were Lane stands.
We were absolutely lane stands to start off. And unfortunately,
Lane has burned all of his goodwill with this stop. >> I
assure you, if there's any way I can prove that to you, I guarantee
you I
>> Okay. All right. No, I'm going to close the door real
quick. Give me just one second. I'll come talk to you again.
I I suppose firefighters could have a good idea of how to get
all of this footage back, right? If if this guy started telling
the story. Dude, the the wife said everything correct to get
like a little bit of charity from the officers, right? The the
wife was totally calm. She just reiterated over and over that,
hey, this guy's got he's got a brain injury. He's slow. He he
probably wasn't processing what you were saying very well. Apparently,
this dude's records were sealed confidential as well. Well, not
before the foyer request got there with all of his all of his
uh arrest footage there.
Him banging his head off the desk. >> Okay, that's not
legal. You can't do >> Can't do what? >> You can't
drive that slow under the speed limit. >> It's a safety
hazard. >> It's a safety hazard for you to be on the road
driving that slow under the speed limit. Correct. Do you have
your driver's license on? >> Sir, I need to get to this
lane. Can you get it off this? I work here. >> Oh, I went
to the wrong video. Whoops. That was when we pulled back from
before. I thought they were reiterating at the beginning. Whoops.
We're here. >> I'm sorry. What was your name again? >> Katie.
So, unfortunately, I do have to take him to jail because he grabbed
me.
>> Okay. I could look past the initial refusal to give
me his ID at first and I didn't I didn't give him 20 chances
to do it, but if I tell someone to give me their ID and they
say no or what for, I understand what you're saying. He was reaching
for the glove box. Um >> Oh, he knows he knows that the
guy said what for what? >> I don't know that that's what
he's looking for. or if he's telling me no or what do you need
my ID for to me that's that's a no. That's I'm not giving it
to you. Okay. The the the problem though is that when I try to
get him out of the car, he grabbed my hand. He pushed my hands
away from him and then I'm trying to put him in handcuffs and
he's pulling and turning away from me. >> Because of that,
I have to take him to >> Is there any way you could >> I
have to take him to jail. >> Is there any way you could
have the mercy in you to view it like someone with autism? You
know that an person would do something similar when someone's
grabbing them. It's like an instinctive response because their
>> if his mental capacity is so diminished that he doesn't
know not to put his hands on a police officer. He should not
have a driver's se >> Oh, it's so brutal because of how
aggressively Lane tries to yank him out of the vehicle, right?
Like if somebody's not understanding what's going on, then yeah,
you're like literally reaching in to yank him out of the vehicle.
Of course, he might react badly. Of course, if if the guy had
just like pushed Lane, like if it was all calm and then he just
like pushed Lane down to the ground or something, that's different.
But Lane escalates so hard and so aggressively that I wouldn't
be shocked if somebody just reacts by going like, "Oh." And the
guy then apologized, says, "Oh, I'm really sorry that I pushed
you. I'm really sorry that I got back in my vehicle. Thank you
for not shooting me, officer license." Okay. So, either he is
more mentally incapacitated than the state of whatever state
his driver's license is out of knows. >> Uh, or he's more
intelligent than you're leading me to believe because I either
way, he's driving a car, so he's got to have at least like an
80 IQ to be able to drive a car. So, if he's got that, >> I'm
not sure what >> he should probably know not to not to,
>> bro. No way, dude. This lane guy is
He's everywhere. Louisiana couple sues uh Monro Monroe County
Sheriff's Office for tough takedown after traffic stop in Florida
Keys, bro. He's get he's every he's all over the place, dude.
He's getting sued now. And this is yesterday.
This is Yes, dude. Lane's ever Why is Lane blowing up? That's
nuts, man. >> Grab a police officer. >> A situation
where an officer is trying to grab him out of a car. So, it's
a a different thing to be in the moment and like I said, but
you know, view it like a person with autism, like their initial
responses to be like, "Someone's grabbing me. Oh my god, let
go."
>> It will just be
>> Oh [__] >> Nated $3. Bro did not deescalate.
>> Okay. Thank you, Reuben. Not your best. Okay. But you've
had you kind of been on fire today, so we're going to let that
one go. All right, guys. If like Raven Rubin, you want to, you
know, give a few bucks to the stream, make the stream go longer,
we are,
what are we? We are, I think, eight subs. Eight subs away from
two more hours on the stream right now. So, if you if you like
the content, you want to donate a couple bucks, make the stream
go longer, go ahead. You can donate now. Um, you can sub through
kick. You could give your Twitch Prime over on the Twitch site
or over on the the Twitch profile, okay? You can give money a
number of ways. You guys know all the ways. All right. There's
also the Patreon, patreon.com/jsdk.
Go ahead, throw a couple bucks in the pot. Make the stream go
longer. Thank you very much. >> Talk to my sergeant. My
sergeant said to take him to jail because he touched me. >> And
listen, at the same time, I understand your perspective, but
you also have to understand his perspective, but also with this
incident, if you go to jail, you also have the ability to go
to court and ar that side of it.
I understand that. I understand that, man. But we still have
to do our job.
It's going to hurt. >> Catherine, here's your uh ID.
Look, I I I understand. I have to take him to jail. Okay, Catherine.
That's That ship has sailed. I have to take him. I I understand.
You know, this this is hard. I don't I don't want to take someone
to jail with a mental disability. But at the same time, if he's
driving a car and I pull him over for a traffic violation, going
10 m hour in a 55 mph zone is a traffic violation. He can't do
that. mercy. >> That That's why That's why I pulled him
over. When I tell the driver of a vehicle on a traffic stop to
give me his driver's license, he has to give it to me. If I tell
him to step out of the >> Please, we can't. Please. >> If
I tell someone to step out of the vehicle under Pennsylvania
versus NIMS, they have to step out of the vehicle. If they refuse,
that is obstruction. >> I understand. I understand all
of that. And I understand from your perspective, you have to
protect yourself.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't understand how this could possibly
be a 55. Actually, that's that's a pretty crazy road where there's
not even a shoulder. They don't even have like a shoulder to
pull into to pull off >> to get home to your own family
and all of that. >> Uh, is it just this little with no
shoulder on it? It's like a major through or something that you
would have a high speed limit on. There's not even a shoulder.
They're like on this little They're on this itty bitty little
road. Okay. All right. >> That trust me, I wish he didn't
have a brain injury. I wish he didn't have those moments where
he doesn't. I'm very sorry that your family has to deal with
>> Catherine. But please, cuz this is something that's
like you're basically putting me in jail, too. >> I'm not
putting you in jail. You're still here. You can take the car
and the boat, go back to your campsite. You can get him out tomorrow.
We'll have first. You You can
look there. There's ways in the court. If he's actually got a
brain injury, you >> I I wouldn't have even given him a
ticket. I was just going to tell him that he was driving slow
and he can't drive that slow on US1. Right. >> And all
I needed was his driver's >> Is there any way you can like
modify the report to where he was falling out of the vehicle
and he grabbed you to brace himself? Not grab. >> I'm not
going to I'm not going to lie. I'm not going to pure, >> dude.
Dude, she's like she's trying so hard,
man. Wait,
no, no, no, no, no. There's just we had we found a couple different
things with this guy, Nyx. Um, listen, it's just it's a one time
I assume it's a onetime thing. Unless Lane's been a busy bee.
Okay. Got to be a onetime thing. for someone I don't know. I'm
going to watch my body camera and handcar camera and I'm going
to go word for word and action for action when I write the report.
I will document in there how you're telling me he has a brain
injury. Uh what was that caused by? >> Um a motor vehicle
motorcycle accident
one night took a lefthand turn in front of us. He actually wasn't
supposed to even live and then they weren't sure if he was going
to be paralyzed or what sort of function he was going to have.
He's made amazing progress. Um, but there's still, you know,
there's deficits just like if you lost a limb, there's things
that are difficult. He lost a a chunk of his brain. So, >> A
bunch of people sent me this footage. The footage was actually
sourced by Arrest Cam Fish and Wildlife. So, check out their
channel where you can see more of the cam. >> Well, when
towing a boat too slow leads to felony charges, >> fish
and wildlife. So, check out their channel where you can see more
of the footage that I cut. I'll link that video >> there.
This guy's going to go over some of the lane arrest stuff here
as well. I'm going to use the bathroom real quick. I'll be right
back and then we're on to the next topic. I'm not 100% sure where
we're going to go next. I think
I think we'll go to maybe the big bungee video and then we can
do um Oh, and then we could do George Santos. George Santos's
pardon. Okay, actually, you know what? We'll do we'll do Santos
and then we'll do the Bungee video for sure. below. If anybody
knows this guy, I would love to hear more information about the
criminal charges, which apparently are unavailable currently.
They're sealed in some way. But as I understand it, they ended
up charging him with multiple misdemeanors and at least one felony
for allegedly assaulting this police officer who, as we heard,
gave this family quite the lecture about following the law. But
talk is cheap, isn't it? As it turns out, this cop has quite
the history with multiple viral videos and his own arrest video,
which does need to go viral. I was going to try to squeeze it
into this video, but there is so much there. And the more I look
into it, the dirtier this whole situation has become because
this cop got arrested before this encounter with this brain injured
man. He should not have had a driver's license to be able to
pull this guy over and lecture him. The more I look into it,
the more a major cover up unravels.
A cover up that everyone needs to see, and I need a little bit
more time to go through it. Tomorrow, I will upload the arrest
video featuring this police officer where he was found at a gas
station in the driver's seat of his car, completely unresponsive.
And you can see how he lies to his colleagues and when he's taken
to the station, he refuses to have his breath tested. That is
supposed to come with consequences, right? How is it that that
criminal violation ends up completely covered up, confidential,
and this cop is right back on the road with a badge and a gun.
You're not going to want to miss part two. >> Okay, hold
on. Now, I corrected Nyx earlier and said there weren't more
Lane videos, but it sure sounds like this guy is saying there
are other viral videos with Lane that aren't this video.
Are there Are there other videos with Lane?
That seems like it's got to be
right? I I feel like there's no way that Lane has other videos.
>> So, subscribe. So, we've we've kind of already watched
some of that stuff, but if I go look open up this guy's thing,
we can we search for Lane in here. Do we got Lane part two right
here? Um, one second. Part two right here. And
Olan Lane. We probably need to find Jonathan Lane here to try
to figure this out. Here, I'll open up part two. Just give me
one second here. >> Sheriff's Office. >> I found
new footage of the court hearing. Wait, what?
I think I feel like this is going to be a meme. Hold on. Can
we watch one Hassan Colorggate Crasho clip from today?
Ah, as a pallet cleanser. Yes. But hold on. What is this? Is
this just going to be
>> I I recognized instantly just this woman. I just totally
recognized this clip. I knew exactly what it was. I let it run.
Okay.
>> That's so impressive. Every time that still gets me.
Okay, he clears it. >> I will just be your pain. clears
the >> Kger donated $3.
>> This guy really needs to stay in his own lane, but apparently
he's the real content cop.
>> Okay, Kger, I appreciate the three. All right, I appreciate
the three. Top Bronson wants me to look at one one clip
of something from Colergate here. Okay, give me a second. The
Hassan crash out from today. Hold on. We should get a time stamp
on this.
We should get a Can we get a time stamp on this? Whenever this
is from Oh, I knew. Hold on. You want to know what he's actually
crashing out about here? Cuz I I identified it instantly. I saw
this clip earlier today. All right. It's the lighting. It's the
lighting difference and the high resolution camera at whatever
this Hollywood Reporter event is. Okay. That's what he's crashing
out about is that he does not look like Hassan [__]
right here. He's not like the frat boy right here. Right. That's
what he's actually upset about here. It's not anything else.
It's not about Ka.
It's just that he has this like bad picture and it's out there
for everybody to see. >> Of you dumb in this goddamn chat.
Oh my god. I hate I hate the left. I hate liberalism. I hate
everything that's going on every single week. I just I hate my
life. I hate streaming. I hate socialism. I hate every single
[__] person who thinks that the the peak of activism
is just being the most annoying holier thou. Holier than thou,
the most ultimately woke leftist. It's just it's I you did it.
You did it. You have unlocked the fuckism within me. Okay. I
am black pill. Nothing will ever get better. We are never going
to make it out. We can't even have a normal non-hostile goddamn
conversation on any of these issues. Everybody just simply wants
to tarp into the wind because they have no power and they recognize
their utter powerlessness in the face of unjustifiable constructs
that we exist under. And the best possible thing you can do is
just be goddamn annoying.
>> Wait, wait, wait. >> Hold on. Is this colorgate
or is this just a political rant?
>> Wait, did he mention Ka here or was this about Ka?
This just him being upset about politics or Yeah, it doesn't
He's not saying anything. He's saying, "I hate the situation
we're in politically." Okay.
Oh god. Oh. Uh, accelerated
optimism. Let's go.
>> I want to I want to just shut it off, dude. I want to
shut everything off. I I just want to go away. If I wasn't so
goddamn stubborn, I would have a long time ago. Oh my lord, dude.
I 100% think you should go on sub only mode. What do you mean?
The most annoying people are literally like the 40 month subscribers.
The person that caused me to viral just now is Hidejoiner or
whatever. And that is like a routine nuisance and an offliner
in this community. Okay? He is the consistent voice of nuisance.
Okay?
What are you talking about? The people that actually brick me,
the people that actually cause me to spiral out of control are
always the people that have been in this community for years
who never shut the up. I have banned them before. I I feel total
empathy for that. Yeah. No, that's that's real. That's >> It's
literally just like I'm not singling him out. He's just one example,
>> but this happens all the
>> This guy is so real right now. I mean, he's he's not
handling it in the best way, but he's so real right now, >> bro.
Anyway, one of the worst aspects of of like this kind of gap.
>> Look, Hassan crashes out immediately. Like a 100 gifted
subs. What was that? There's like a 100 gifted sub. Oh my goodness.
Oh, he crashes out for two seconds. And it's immediately 100
gifted sub. 100 gifted subs get instantly. >> One of the
worst aspects well of gathering online is that >> I will
just be your pay. Oh, hold on.
>> Hey, I just got here and this is crazy, but here's my
money. Shock column maybe.
>> Oh, listen. I I think I said don't donate with puns
anymore to re with if you're not Reuben Rubin. And people took
that as like a >> a begging on my part for more puns. No,
it wasn't. It was a genuine feeling. Stop donating puns. Thank
you. Unless you're Reben Rubin, but thank you for the five gummy
verse. I appreciate it. The Reddit player doesn't respond to
anything. If you click in the middle of the Reddit player, if
you hit your space bar, it just goes down. >> This is the
most dog web player on the entire internet. >> Don't behave
like this in the real world. Ironically, what I was talking about.
That's why I have so much hope for the future of America when
I'm out in the streets, right? Cuz I see grandparents and I see
kids and I see regular ass folk that see right from wrong and
they say, "Fuck this. What do you mean? You're just like kidnapping
my neighbors. Get the out of here." And they protest and that
gives me confidence. And then when I go back to the internet
and I get yelled at by a bunch of screenager iPad babies who
are 38 years old who think that the most like radical socialist
position is to constantly chirp in a Twitch streamer's chat
and and hyper How is it not >> is everything and then like
refuse to understand like broader points. Okay. Refuse to be
open-minded. Then I'm blackpilled again. It's virtually impossible
not to be black if you're online all the time. Everything that
we do here is so bad. It's so bad. >> I don't Is that like
a crash? I honestly he's just he's blackpilled. I feel like people
thought he thought this. I I don't even know. Is this like new
information? This how I thought he thought before.
Like I I don't know.
I just felt like that's all opinions he already had. Maybe maybe
not.
I don't know. I I didn't hear anything new there.
But that's cool. Listen, Hassan's feeling pressure. Hassan's
like getting mad and getting a lot of donations. That's rough,
dude. I wish I couldn't imagine being Hassan. Okay. Oh, Ka's
back. Let's look. Ka the slave is back.
The slave is back in position for the stream. You love to see
it. Okay. All right. You would hate to be Hassan. It must be
terrible. It must be awful. I can't imagine. Framing is so dishonest.
Well, welcome to literally everything.
h I just can't, man. I can't with a bunch of these people. I
I wish Han would stop doing politics. He's so much better at
non-political streams. I understand it's his whole brand now,
but he he should just do other streams. He could be like a big
streamer again. He could just have fun again. I don't know.
politics aren't his forte to begin with. I understand that's
his niche now.
Let other people take over. They could do it better. Bro, he
watched that gay or straight show absolute content. All right.
All right. Okay. Where were we on this guy? I think we were on
part two of this. I just wanted to see. I don't think I want
to watch his like arrest since we went through it already. I'd
maybe do
another one of his videos if he does have another video here
of him being like super abusive again. That would be pretty interesting.
But other than that, I'm probably going to move on to the next
piece of content. Maybe we go over George Santos, okay? Because
I don't know if you guys saw. All right,
breaking news today.
Donald Trump
in an act I cannot possibly explain. It does not It makes no
political sense. It makes no like clout sense. It doesn't I don't
think George Santos could pay him. I literally don't understand.
But apparently Donald Trump has commuted the sentence of former
Congressman George
just today.
And the reasoning for this is baffling.
Like I don't understand it at all. Can anybody give me like a
solid reason for wanting to do this?
I don't get it. I literally don't get it. It's like was there
some bad news for Trump today that he's trying to like flood
out? Is he trying to flood the zone with I don't even know, man.
He wants us to accept drag queens. Well, it's not what he said
in his truth social post, let me tell you.
Let's uh let's look at the story accompanying this real quick
and then I've got a couple other articles to go along with this.
Trump commutes prison sentence of ex GOP rep George Santos. President
Donald Trump on Friday evening said he has commuted the prison
sentence of George Santos, releasing the disgraced former Republican
congressman immediately. Santos, 37, served in the House for
less than a year before he was expelled from Congress under a
cloud of scandal in December 2023.
In a flattery fililled letter published this week, Santos directly
asked Trump directly for clemency. Wait, what?
Hold on. I I need to find this letter. I need to find this letter.
This is crazy,
dude. Can we Hold on. I need to see. Somebody's got the full
Okay, hold on. Maybe they've Maybe they'll have it here somewhere.
But I got to Now I have to find this, dude. I got to find this
cuz what the
Oh, Yasher Lee posted it. Okay. Okay, good. All right. This needs
to go along with this. This is crazy. This isn't an of course
situation
breaking. President Trump says he has commuted the sentence of
former Congressman George Santos. And then
this is apparently the the letter. Uh President Trump has allowed
Santos to spend three months behind bars and has never expressed
any real concern for him. And it's not because he's gay. Santos's
biggest public supporter has been Marjgery Taylor Green, whose
relationship with Trump hasn't been that great lately. Santos
wrote this letter to the president two days ago pleading for
his clemency. Okay, we'll read this in just a second.
Dude, there's no way. He's just like, "Please, please, mister,
please, please commute the sentence. It's terrible in here."
And Trump was like, "You know what? Yeah, yeah, you're fine.
You who cares about all the fraud? Who cares about all the lies?
Who cares about any of that? Okay, you can go free. You can go.
You You seem like you regret it."
Okay. Okay. Never mind. I'm not going to read here because um
I have to read the truth social post. All right. I'm not going
to read this. I have to read the truth social post first because
it's like crazy the way he describes it. All right.
George Santos was somewhat of a rogue, but there are many rogues
throughout our country that aren't forced to serve seven years
in prison. I started to think about George when the subject of
Democrat Senator Richard Dang
Blumenthal Dan Dick Blumenthal came up again. As everyone remembers,
Daang stated for almost 20 years that he was a proud Vietnam
veteran, having endured the worst of the war, watched the wounded
and dead as he raced up hills and down in the valleys, blood
streaming from his face. He was a great hero. He would leak to
any and all who would listen. And then it happened. He was a
complete and total fraud. He never went to Vietnam. He never
saw Vietnam. He never experienced the battles there or anywhere
else. His war hero status and even minimal service to our military
was totally and completely made up. This is far worse than what
George Santos did. And at least Santos had the courage, conviction,
and intelligence to always vote Republican. I very much doubt
that. George has been in solitary confinement for long stretches
of time and by all accounts has been horribly mistreated. Therefore,
I just signed a commutation releasing George Santos from prison
immediately.
Good luck, George. Have a great life. Bro, by all accounts, it's
just George's account, right? George is just like, "Mr. Trump,
Mr. Trump, I'm being abused."
And that's all it was. Let's read the letter. Let's see. Let's
see this OB story.
Didn't Trump not even always vote Republican? Great point, Turnup.
Yes, Trump famously was a Democrat at different points.